namo tassa bhagavad-dho aradho samasambuddhasam namo tassa bhagavad-dho aradho samasambuddhasam namo tassa bhagavad-dho aradho
Hommage au Bouddha, le noble bienheureux, pleinement éveillé de par lui-même.
Donc ce soir, j'ai pensé que nous pouvions explorer un peu mieux les cinq obstacles.
Et parler un peu des sept facteurs de l'enlightenment.
Et il parlait un peu des sept facteurs de l'éveil.
J'ai pensé que c'était le Noël.
Les belles de jingle.
Donc, le Bouddha parle des défaillances.
Donc, le Bouddha a parlé des obstacles.
Non, non, des défaillements.
Des défaillements, c'est quoi?
Des défaillements.
Quelques-uns veulent dire?
La pureté?
Non.
Non, non, c'est Kilesa.
Il doit y avoir un scolaire de Pali ici.
Non.
Kilesa est... Kilesa.
Kilesa, oui, c'est...
Ok.
Ah, si, vous avez raison.
Donc, Kilesa, c'est toutes les choses qui sont impures en nous.
Non, pardon, pas impures.
Qui sont non bénéfiques, justement.
On utilise toujours des termes non moralisateurs.
Il faut garder ces termes-là.
En le plus tard dans la vie du Bouddha, ils ont commencé à construire 10 de ces défaillances.
Donc, dans la vie postérieure du Bouddha, enfin dans la fin de vie du Bouddha, ils ont transformé ça en dix impuretés, on va dire, c'est le terme musulman, je crois.
Ah, dix.
Dix, oui.
Mais bien sûr, il y a de nombreuses défaillances.
Mais bien sûr, il y en a un nombre innombrable.
Ça, c'est ce dont nous faisons l'expérience pendant la journée.
Et il y a aussi la compréhension qu'il y a donc...
Des impuretés, si quelqu'un trouve un terme meilleur, des impuretés qui sont constamment en dessous là, énergétiquement.
Donc il y a la conception d'une sorte d'inconscient dans les enseignements bouddhiques.
Mais connaître ces listes n'est pas particulièrement utile.
Mais bon, connaître la liste de ces impuretés qui ont été recensées n'est pas particulièrement aidant.
Et par contre, quand il vient aux enseignements de la manière dont on peut et doit pratiquer, la liste est différente.
Et ça, c'est les cinq obstacles.
Donc, les cinq impuretés sont
Donc, les cinq obstacles sont beaucoup plus faciles à se souvenir que les dix impuretés et les dix impuretés potentielles.
Pour ceux d'entre vous qui connaissent le Pali, Kilesa and Busaya.
Donc, ces hindrances, elles...
Donc, ces obstacles séparent d'une manière claire pour nous les différents types d'impuretés que nous avons, de difficultés.
Donc, le premier obstacle, c'est tous les désirs que nous avons.
Maintenant, si vous êtes assis ici,
Et puis soudain, un désir arrive dans votre esprit.
Par exemple, vous avez un désir qui vous submerge de visiter le Royaume-Uni.
Yes, and you're in England and there's no rain and everybody's beautiful.
Vous êtes en Angleterre et il n'y a pas de pluie et tous les gens sont beaux.
So, when you wake up, you say, ah, you see, planning, planning.
So now, you have to come back to the body
Et donc il faut revenir au corps.
Et sentir ce désir à l'intérieur.
Ce désir est une énergie potentielle.
Et ça ne prend qu'un moment de tension intérieure et ça vous prend de nouveau à l'intérieur.
Et il n'y a besoin que d'une seconde, d'un centième de seconde d'inattention et paf, vous êtes au Royaume-Uni.
Donc quand vous ressentez ce désir, quand vous sentez ce désir, il faut rester avec.
Et c'est là où la notation, les notes mentales peuvent être d'une grande aide.
Parce que vous pouvez vous dire de manière continue désir, désir, désir.
Et ça, ça occupe l'esprit et l'intellect.
Mais votre attention est
et les sensations liées au désir dans le corps.
Et il faut que vous soyez conscient de cette pulsion de retourner dans les rêveries.
Donc il faut que vous attendiez jusqu'à ce que petit à petit cela disparaisse.
Et à chaque fois que vous faites cela, vous minez ce désir compulsif de visiter le Royaume-Uni.
Malheureusement !
Donc c'est vraiment important que l'on reste avec le désir jusqu'à ce qu'il disparaisse complètement, qu'il meurt totalement.
Et la raison, c'est parce que quand le désir a disparu complètement, ce n'est pas que l'énergie a disparu, qu'elle a été gaspillée.
En fait, systématiquement, elle se retourne en son opposé.
Il y a toujours une transformation.
Et quand ce désir complètement finit, vous pouvez expérimenter ce magnifique sens
Et quand ce désir est complètement terminé, vous ferez probablement l'expérience du contentement.
Et ça, c'est un toucher, un soupçon de l'esprit du Bouddha.
L'esprit du Bouddha est dans un état de contentement perpétuel.
Quelqu'un s'est plaint au Bouddha.
Il lui a dit, cet entraînement que vous nous faites faire, c'est très dur.
Et le Bouddha a dit, oui, mais au final, vous atteignez l'Ibana.
Oui, mais elle vous a répondu, oui d'accord, mais à la fin vous réalisez la libération, vous atteignez le nirvana.
Et la question c'est, le nirvana, et alors ?
Et donc, quand vous avez atteint le nirvana, dit le Bouddha, en fait, vous êtes dans le contentement et heureux de cela.
Ah !
Tutti et sukha vahati.
That's the power.
Ne compagnie, c'est ça.
Tutti et sukha vahati.
Tutti frutti.
All the fruits are there of your practice.
Donc, tous les fruits de votre pratique sont là.
Ah !
Donc, quand on fait l'expérience de la fin du désir et de cet état de contentement paisible, c'est exactement là où nous souhaitons aller, là où nous allons, nous nous dirigeons vers cet état.
Et peu importe le désir, la technique est toujours la même.
Donc la technique c'est toujours la même chose.
Donc sortir du flux des rêveries, du désir, etc.
Être bien conscient de ce qui se passe, revenir au corps et rester avec ce qu'il y a dans le corps jusqu'à ce que ça disparaisse.
Malheureusement, si on ne fait pas ça, ce désir commence à grandir.
C'est une erreur de quelqu'un qui a pratiqué beaucoup.
Il y a un petit peu de paresse qui arrive dans la pratique, parfois au bout de pratiques assez longues, si on pratique depuis longtemps.
Il n'y a pas assez d'effort pour rester avec ce désir.
Et parce qu'il n'y a pas cet effort, il y a ce moment d'inattention.
Et tout à coup, vous allez retourner au Royaume-Uni.
Et si vous ne le regardez pas, vous allez passer une heure dans le Royaume-Uni.
vous serez au Royaume-Uni dans votre tête donc parfois cela nécessite un vrai effort pour rester là avec ce qui se passe et alors maintenant bien sûr il y a l'autre côté toutes ces choses que nous n'aimons pas
Alors, par exemple, nous avons la colère.
La chose qui se passe avec la colère, c'est que nous aimons être en colère.
Nous aimons crier sur les autres.
C'est rigolo.
Si vous pouviez même les taper, ce serait encore mieux.
Il y a une cruauté qui est sous cette colère, cette haine.
Et là, c'est la même chose que n'importe quel désir.
Il faut faire la même chose.
Maintenant, l'angoisse est un état mental très difficile à rester avec.
Il y a parfois encore plus d'énergie dans la colère que dans le désir.
Et parfois, quand votre esprit s'éloigne, vous devez être très clair.
Qu'est-ce que c'est que vous êtes ?
Qu'est-ce qui empêche l'angoisse ?
Et parfois, quand votre esprit vagabonde, il faut être très clair sur ce qui donne du jus à votre colère.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière votre colère ?
Est-ce que c'est, par exemple, quelque chose qui ressemble à du ressentiment ?
C'est parce que vous ne voulez pas pardonner.
Et parfois, vous entendez des gens dire, je ne peux pas pardonner.
Mais bien sûr que tout le monde peut pardonner à tout le monde.
Donc, quand quelqu'un dit, je ne peux pas pardonner à tout le monde,
Et donc quand quelqu'un dit je ne peux pas pardonner cela, il se comporte comme un petit enfant.
Quand un enfant ne veut pas aller au lit et veut rester debout, il dit je ne peux pas dormir.
Mais vraiment, je ne veux pas dormir.
Mais en vérité, c'est plutôt « je ne veux pas dormir, je ne vais pas dormir ».
En réalité, quelqu'un qui dit « je ne peux pas pardonner » veut dire « je ne veux pas pardonner, je ne vais pas pardonner ».
Donc, il nous
Parce que ça ne pourrait pas avoir été une décision absolument consciente.
Parce qu'il se peut que ce ne soit pas une décision tout à fait consciente que celle de ne pas pardonner.
Parce qu'un certain nombre de nos habitudes proviennent de notre enfance, de notre petite enfance.
Par exemple, on trouve des gens qui enchaînent les relations sentimentales.
Et on trouve qu'en réalité, très souvent, ils disent « c'est de sa faute ».
Et s'ils se réveillent, peut-être qu'ils vont réaliser « peut-être que c'est moi, en fait ».
Il y a beaucoup de notre caractère et de notre personnalité dont nous ne sommes pas entièrement conscients.
Une des difficultés à accepter est la qualité de la jalousie.
Et une des impuretés qu'il est vraiment difficile d'accepter, c'est celle de la jalousie.
Parfois, il nous arrive de dire, j'envis cette personne.
Mais en réalité, quand on regarde plus attentivement, on est jaloux de cette personne.
Parce que la jalousie veut ce qu'elle veut.
Wanting what they want, or wanting what they get, or...
No, wanting, sorry, yes, wanting what they have, excuse me.
Ok, parce que la jalousie, c'est le fait de vouloir ce que l'autre a.
And hating them for having it.
Et de les haïr pour l'avoir, cette chose qu'ils n'auront rien à voir.
But it also means that I'm inferior to them.
Et cela veut dire aussi que je me sens inférieur à eux.
And that's difficult for us to accept.
Et ça c'est difficile pour nous d'accepter de nous sentir inférieurs.
Donc tous ces obstacles subtils, ils commencent à se manifester si on a l'ouverture suffisante pour les voir.
Donc par exemple, je ne crois pas qu'il n'existe une seule personne dans une seule société au monde qui n'a aucun préjugé.
Donc on trouvera, par exemple, des préjugés liés à l'âge, au genre, à la sexualité, à la race.
Maintenant, si nous le dénions, si nous disons « Oh non, non, je n'ai pas de préjugés », nous n'aurons jamais vraiment ouvert et puissons-nous purifier.
Donc, si on est dans le déni du fait qu'on a aussi, nous aussi, des préjugés, alors on ne sera jamais capable de s'ouvrir à ces préjugés et de nous en purifier.
J'ai remarqué que ces jours-ci, certains parlementaires essayent de faire facile à des gens d'accepter cela.
J'ai remarqué que de nos jours, certains orateurs font leur possible pour rendre cela beaucoup plus acceptable aux autres d'avoir des préjugés.
Ils appellent cela
Des biais.
Tu peux avoir un biais à ta race, à ton sexe, à ta classe, au fait d'être handicapé ou pas, etc.
On a des biais.
C'est-à-dire d'où on est.
Donc, ce terme biais, il suggère que c'est seulement des potentialités.
C'est seulement quand vous les activez, à travers la parole, l'action et la pensée,
Donc c'est uniquement quand vous les activez à travers la pensée, la parole ou l'action qui deviennent des préjugés.
Mais tout cela doit être purifié à travers le cœur.
Et cela ne peut pas être purifié à part dans la conscience.
Et donc, quand on s'aperçoit de quelque chose et qu'on lui donne son vrai nom et qu'on dit ça, c'est un préjugé.
Et quand on vient à l'intérieur de nous, il faut que nous restions avec cet état mental difficile.
Et vous devez accepter le sentiment de...
Il nous faut accepter le sentiment, l'énergie de honte et de culpabilité associée au fait d'avoir des préjugés.
On pensait qu'on n'avait aucun préjugé et tout à coup on s'aperçoit qu'on a des préjugés à l'intérieur de nous.
Et quand on a le cœur ouvert à cela, on est beaucoup plus prompt à s'apercevoir dans notre vie quotidienne de l'existence de ces préjugés à l'intérieur de nous.
Et parce qu'on en a conscience, on peut les laisser disparaître.
Et de cette façon,
Et de cette manière, on mine de manière sûre et certaine ces états mentaux négatifs.
Et donc tout ça, ça se rattache à la qualité, la caractéristique de l'aversion.
Et on peut aussi inclure l'anxiété et le peur.
l'anxiété et la peur ce sont aussi des ressentis des énergies très difficiles à ressentir on préfère plutôt appeler un ami allumer la télé n'importe quoi et le sentiment d'isolement aussi
Donc, si vous restez avec ces états mentaux jusqu'à ce qu'ils disparaissent complètement, vous verrez la transformation.
Vous serez surpris de la peur qui, quand elle termine, se transforme en amour.
elle se retourne en amour.
Et la même chose avec le sentiment d'isolement, de solitude.
Donc si vous restez avec le sentiment d'isolement jusqu'à ce qu'il disparaisse
Et non douloureuse.
Mais il faut rester jusqu'à la fin, bien sûr, jusqu'à ce que ça disparaisse, pour qu'il y ait ce moment de retournement.
Cela ne veut pas dire que si vous ne restez pas jusqu'à la fin, la transformation ne survient pas.
Mais le fait de voir ce moment de transformation, ça, ça vous donne confiance dans la pratique.
Et c'est à travers ce processus qu'il y a la purification du cœur.
Donc, dans le langage psychothérapeutique, c'est la purification.
Et donc dans le langage thérapeutique, psychothérapeutique, ça s'appelle la guérison.
Et le prochain, c'est ce que mon enseignant appelait nos deux bons amis.
Donc, la torpeur et la léthargie.
Ces petites voix qui disent tu as besoin de te reposer.
Juste dix minutes.
Donc, c'est à distinguer, bien sûr, de la vraie fatigue.
Bien sûr, c'est à distinguer de la fatigue véritable.
Et d'où survient ce désir de sombrer dans l'annihilation ?
Donc on a mentionné ce matin...
pas de souffrance.
Donc parfois, quand on est trop en dépression, quand les choses deviennent trop difficiles, on essaie de se supprimer.
se supprimer est un petit suicide.
Plus précisément, se débarrasser de tout sentiment du soi, donc être dans l'oubli, c'est un petit suicide.
Il y a aussi une autre raison pour laquelle nous développons ce désir
C'est parce que quand on se réveille, par exemple le week-end, on se retourne dans le lit et...
oh excuse-moi on se retourne dans le lit and then we fall asleep again then you roll over for a bit more roasting donc on se retourne dans le lit pour un peu plus de roasting like in a like in cooking pour un peu se faire dorer un petit peu ah then you wake
on se réveille, on voit l'heure qu'il est et allez hop, on recommence donc c'est un petit niveau subliminaux très agréable d'être pas tout à fait réveillé pas tout à fait endormi mais ce dont nous faisons l'expérience dans la méditation
lourdeur de cela.
Et donc, la compulsion de tomber endormi.
Et ça, c'est dans notre psyché.
Et cela ne peut être libéré jusqu'à ce que ça parvienne à la conscience tant qu'on n'a pas parvenu à la conscience.
C'est pour ça qu'il nous faut rester vie.
Donc s'il y a la léthargie dans la tête il faut de manière continue bouger à l'intérieur de la tête.
C'est un acte d'intention
Donc à chaque fois que vous bougez votre attention, c'est un acte d'intention.
Et donc c'est une manière de renforcer ses capacités, son pouvoir.
Donc cela donne à l'attention un peu plus d'énergie pour rester éveillé.
Et vous serez surpris.
Vous pouvez vous réveiller comme une lampe de lumière dans cette atmosphère douce.
Et vous serez surpris, vous pourriez vous réveiller comme un phare ou une lumière éclatante dans cette atmosphère de léthargie.
lorsque la conscience devient complètement détachée de ce sens de léthargie.
Et cela permet à cette mauvaise énergie de s'exhauster.
Et cela permet à cette énergie négative de s'épuiser elle-même.
Et c'est pareil avec le fait de se sentir lourd dans le corps.
Donc dans ces cas-là, il faut faire du scan corporel en partant des pieds vers la tête, parce que cela réveille l'énergie, cela la remonte.
Et découvrez où est-ce que c'est que vous vous sentez fatigué et compressé.
Peut-être que vous allez avoir la surprise de trouver beaucoup de fatigue dans vos jambes.
Et dans le corps, dans la poitrine.
Mais vous devez me dire si vous avez trouvé de la fatigue au bout de votre nez.
Je n'ai jamais senti fatigué au bout de mon nez.
Donc, mettre votre attention sur quelque chose qui n'est pas fatigué vous permet de vous réveiller un peu.
et en mettant votre attention sur une partie du corps qui n'est pas fatiguée alors cela vous permet de vous réveiller un peu et puis de ressentir cette lourdeur et on en a beaucoup dans notre système c'est un très gros obstacle
Le quatrième obstacle, c'est l'agitation.
C'est soit l'esprit qui est très agité, qui devient fou.
Et parfois, c'est à tel point qu'on peut penser qu'on devient fou nous-mêmes.
Et le corps peut être aussi plein d'agitation.
Et donc quand l'esprit est très agité, il faut être très patient et passer son temps à revenir au corps.
Et avec le corps, encore une fois, vous pouvez descendre le corps en ressentant cette agitation.
Donc avec le corps, dans ce cas-là, on peut partir du haut du corps pour redescendre et ressentir l'agitation dans le corps.
Et dans cette catégorie, il y a aussi les effets secondaires qui proviennent d'actions non bénéfiques.
Donc, la honte, la culpabilité et le remords.
Ça aussi, cela crée beaucoup d'agitation.
Et là encore, c'est parfois très difficile de rester calme.
ses remords sa culpabilité et une chose qui peut vraiment aider à accepter ces états mentaux difficiles c'est l'amour bienveillant il nous faut développer une attitude de soin
à l'égard de notre cœur.
Donc, dessous, il y a une attitude de soin du cœur qui est malade.
Et quand nous faisons cela, alors cela évite
Cela éloigne l'inversion, le ne pas vouloir ressentir ces états.
Cela rend cela beaucoup plus facile de rester avec ces états mentaux.
De rester au milieu des bombardements.
Et le dernier obstacle, c'est le doute.
Et ce doute est un doute sceptique.
D'avoir des doutes au sujet du dharma, tant que ça nous conduit à investiguer, c'est un bon doute.
C'est un sens du questionnement que l'on trouve chez les scientifiques ou chez les philosophes.
As long as there is an openness to receive information, not to block anything,
Tant qu'il y a une ouverture au fait de recevoir des informations et de ne rien bloquer.
Mais le doute sceptique vous empêche d'agir.
Même dans la vie quotidienne.
Par exemple, vous postulez pour un emploi
Et vous avez des doutes sur votre capacité à remplir cet emploi.
Et vous obtenez le travail.
Mais l'absence de confiance en vous vous mine.
Et vous dites que vous ne l'obtenez pas, que vous avez perdu une opportunité.
Par exemple, vous dites, finalement, non, je ne prends pas le travail et vous avez perdu cette opportunité.
Et c'est la même chose avec les relations sentimentales.
Vous ne savez pas si cette personne est bien pour vous.
Vous êtes submergé par le doute, oui, peut-être, non, oui, non, oui, non, et vous faites toute une liste.
Et avant que vous puissiez prendre une décision, l'autre est parti.
Et qu'il en avait marre de vous.
Donc le doute sceptique est vraiment quelque chose qui tue la vie.
Et si vous regardez dans le doute, je pense que vous allez trouver la peur.
Cela sera la peur d'échouer ou la peur d'être dominé.
Donc, si vous regardez dessous ce qui se passe, vous verrez, vous devez prendre une décision, il y a quelque chose qui vous arrête.
Donc comment est-ce qu'on dépasse cela ?
Il faut faire un saut de foi, un saut de confiance.
Et d'être prêt à échouer le cas échéant.
À partir du moment où on est confortable avec le sentiment, avec le fait d'échouer, où est le problème ?
Vous continuez à essayer.
C'est pareil dans notre pratique, vous voyez ?
Donc vous voyez, c'est la même chose dans notre pratique.
Par exemple, si vous dites, tout le monde peut le faire, mais moi non.
Ah, je ne suis pas bien, je suis nul, je suis sans valeur.
Donc si vous investiguez cela au niveau du cœur, pas par la pensée, le sentiment de
Le ressenti associé au fait de se dévaloriser intérieurement.
Donc il faut rester avec jusqu'à ce que cela s'épuise.
Donc ce qui fait que les doutes sont si difficiles, c'est l'identité.
donc il faut rester avec ces états mentaux patiemment en attendant qu'ils passent donc le Bouddha a dit il nous faut épuiser ces états mentaux
Et qu'il nous faut à chaque fois qu'ils surviennent
So I shall finish there this evening and talk more about the more fundamental reasons as to why we have these hindrances in the first place tomorrow.
Donc je vais rester avec ça pour l'instant et je parlerai demain de la raison pour laquelle nous avons fondamentalement ces obstacles en nous.
J'espérais dire quelques mots des facteurs de l'éveil.
Pour vous donner de l'espoir.
Malheureusement, le temps est sorti.
Mais malheureusement, il ne reste plus de temps.
Donc, juste pour lever votre énergie et votre espoir, les sept facteurs de l'éveil sont ceux que nous avons pratiqués ce matin.
Donc, rappelez-vous, c'est cette connaissance, cette vraie connaissance dont nous avons parlé.
Donc, souvenez-vous, nous avons parlé de l'attention juste, de la conscience juste.
Et aussi de la stabilité de l'attention.
Et l'effort pour maintenir cette attention, cette stabilité.
Et l'effort, ce n'est pas d'essayer d'atteindre quelque chose.
seulement de faire attention.
Et à l'intérieur de cette attention, de cette conscience, il y a un sens du calme.
Et cela soutient le sens de l'intérêt, de la curiosité.
Alors, même si nous parlons de l'awareness, dans les discourses, il y a toujours...
Et bien que l'on parle d'attention et de conscience dans les discours du Bouddha, c'est toujours associé à l'intuition.
Il y a trois mots qui sont toujours associés ensemble.
Atapi means real committed effort.
profondément engagé, réellement engagé, un vrai engagement dans l'effort.
Avec l'intelligence intuitive.
Et en étant conscient.
C'est la combinaison de sati et de panya.
D'abord vous regardez, et ensuite vous voyez.
D'abord, on regarde et après, on voit.
Donc, on entend des gens qui se grattent le nez ?
Non, non, non.
J'espère non.
Juste...
On entend des bruits qui grattent.
On entend des choses qui tient, on va dire ça comme ça peut-être.
Et donc on regarde.
Après vous voyez.
C'est bien ça.
Donc on regarde et après on voit.
Ce sont des qualités qui sont à l'intérieur de nous.
Donc il y a ce sens général d'un cœur ouvert, d'un esprit ouvert.
Pas de résistance.
C'est l'équanimité.
Et on investigue plus particulièrement les trois caractéristiques de l'existence.
Comment nous créons la souffrance, la souffrance pour nous-mêmes, l'impermanence et le non-soi.
Ça c'est le côté...
de notre pratique je peux seulement espérer que mes mots ont été d'une quelconque assistance que je n'ai pas causé plus de confusion et que par votre clarté d'entendre
Et que par la clarté de votre compréhension et votre engagement constant, vous serez libérés de toutes vos souffrances.
Plus tôt que plus tard.